Do you have any experience with meningioma?
So, meningioma is tuber on the meninges.
That's a part of the brain, the cases, the nerves and brain itself.
I was wondering if there's a holistic treatment that
restores the secretion of merlin enzyme and that suppresses tuber growth.
So, with meningioma, there is a...
So, with the different tumors, with the different nerve tumors,
there's a gene called the EDF2 gene that is neurofibroma factor 2 or something like that.
Because there are with neurofibromas, that's a common disorder that is genetic,
where a person will get these lumps all over and these are fibrous tumors that are benign,
and typically stay benign, but it's genetic and it can be embarrassing and it's just,
it's not, you know, doesn't look good, you can get them on your face and it's unpleasant.
Well, they found that it's a defect in this gene and it's a tumor suppressor gene.
So, they called it neurofibroma 2, I think, and it's a tumor suppressor gene.
And the tumor suppressor gene makes an enzyme which is called merlin.
And that merlin enzyme then helps silence tumor growth.
So, the purpose of tumor suppressor genes is that let's say if I have a cancer that starts in a cell.
So, good, cancer starts with just one cell, it's a healthy, it's a normal cell that is damaged.
So, something gets inside that cell, whether it's a toxin or a biotoxin of some sort,
that damages the nucleus so that it starts a reproductive phase so that it starts to rapidly reproduce.
Well, then it kicks on these tumor suppressor genes, this is why everybody doesn't have cancer.
So, these tumor suppressor genes kick on and they produce enzymes that stimulate
intrinsic apoptotic cycles. So, they stimulate the death of the cell from the inside.
So, apoptosis is normal programs cell death and that's what you want to stimulate.
So, that's what a tumor suppressor gene basically turns on
is this intrinsic apoptosis. So, the cancer cell dies and then you never know you had cancer.
So, the truth is is that everybody has cancer all the time, but your body is fighting it and destroyed it
largely due to these tumor suppressor genes. But if I have genetic defects in these tumor suppressor
then I'm not causing this intrinsic apoptotic response. I'm getting a less intrinsic apoptotic response.
So, I have a greater chance that this continues to reproduce, whether it's a tumor or whether it's
a malignant cancer. Now, with NF2 defects, you could get neurofibromatosis, but you could also get
other brain tumors. Admitigiomas are one of those things. So, honestly, I haven't really researched
what would be the nutritional intervention for someone with NF2 defects, but I will say in general,
with so many of the other tumor suppressor genes, if a person has defects in those tumor suppressor
genes, one major component that can be an intervention would be a curcumin. So, curcumin or tumor
can help, has been proven to help those with P53 gene defects, which is another tumor suppressor
genes with BRCA gene defects. Also, Resveratrol and great TX tract can help with those. And I think that
the mechanism of action on that is that it decreases IL-6 and decreases the expression of M-TOR.
So, M-TOR is a whole other discussion, and I actually have some videos on M-TOR. I do know that
that Merlin and the tumor suppressor gene that's associated with it does tie to M-TOR as well.
And lack thereof production of Merlin increases M-TOR function. And go to, let's see,
I bet you if you go to cuttersclinic.com and you search for M-TOR, M capital small M capital TOR.
You'll see that pathway now. You'll see some videos I created. If it's not on cuttersclinic.com,
if you go to our YouTube channel or our videos.com, or you search for M-TOR, you'll see some videos I
created on that. The M-TOR pathway is essential to understand if you have tumors or cancer,
because what you want to do is to suppress that M-TOR pathway. Now, some of the things that,
again, how would you deal with this? Some of the things that stimulate the M-TOR pathway even more
are listed in that video. So I would think from a dietary standpoint,
things like dairy stimulate the M-TOR pathway. That's why it's good for most cancer patients to be
off of dairy, because it has growth factors in it. Things that will increase IGF-1 levels,
things that will increase estrogen levels and in balance as it hormones. So if you look through that,
I think you'll find the best information on that.